Diana Spencer Princess of Wales died on
the 31st of August 1997 aged just 36
what sudden people more than anything
was a suspicious circumstances
surrounding her death and rumors of
murder and betrayal this caused mass
hysteria but to this day we still don't
fully understand what happened that
night
on and off the streets of Paris there
have been many theories as to the reason
for her death
many suggest corruption inside the royal
family and mi5 but what actually
happened on that night well here's some
of the weirdest facts and hidden
evidence surrounding Diana's death the
card Diana was in at the time of the
crash a black mercedes s 280 was the
only available car that night but the
car had previously been stolen and only
recently found by the rental company who
owned the car when it was recovered the
only thing missing from the car was an
on-board computer chip this chip
controlled the car's navigation
acceleration steering and braking some
believe the original computer chip was
replaced with adopted one that allowed
remote control of the vehicle
which would easily allow for a staged
crash depending on which report you read
the ambulance took between 1 hour and 15
minutes and 1 hour and 40 minutes to get
to the hospital
in the middle of the night however the
journey should only take 11 minutes in
rush hour
Mercedes point-blank Lee refused to
inspect the wreckage many believe
because an experienced mercedes engineer
would immediately be able to detect that
the car had been tampered with
journalists were told our right not to
interview anyone who mentioned
murder although the general consensus
amongst the public alluded to murder the
media never mentioned it just a few
months before her death diana criticized
the royal family on the bbc's panorama
program diana predicted her own death
she had given her butler and lawyer
hundred in note for safekeeping the note
explained that Prince Charles was
planning a car accident to kill her the
letter reads I am sitting at my desk
today longing for someone to hook me and
encouraged me to keep strong and hold my
head high this particular phase in my
life is the most dangerous
my husband is planning an accident in my
car brake failure or some serious head
injury in order to make the path clear
for him to marry digging Camilla is
nothing more than a decoy so we are
being used by the man in every sense of
the word the ambulance driver was
ordered by the on-board doctor to stop
and park outside Paris's Natural History
Museum because Diana was in a critical
condition
however the hospital entrance was in
plain view of the part ambulance but no
one rushed over to help it would have
only taken the ambulance in over 30
seconds to drive to the hospital some
believe it was in the ambulance journey
that her injuries were purposely made
worse to ensure her death against all
French laws immediately a team of
embalmers
illegally embalmed Diana's
body whilst it was still worn this made
any post-mortem examinations extremely
difficult to perform therefore doctors
were unable to find out if there had
been any tampering with her body during
the ambulance journey at the same time
as the embalming the tunnel was washed
down and opened for public use in just a
couple of hours
the driver Henri Paul who died in the
car crash was accused of consuming
quoting quote grossly excessive
quantities of alcohol and that his
reckless driving whilst under the
influence of alcohol caused the crash
although almost every person who talked
to Henri Paul that night has said that
he did not appear intoxicated before the
crash blood samples apparently taken
from Henry Paul after the crash showed
that he was hopelessly drunk but was it
really his blood interestingly the blood
contained a medicine called albendazole
which Henry's doctor said he was never
prescribed but even more bizarrely the
same batch of blood samples contained no
trace of another medicine called a
canvas Drake which Henry Paul had been
prescribed the intention of this video
is not to point fingers
I'm only presenting the evidence as it
has been reported I'll leave it to you
to form your own opinion thanks for
watching until next time